you used to do stand-up comedy and then
you were writing regularly for different
great comedians and TV shows then you
get this massive movie career and you
have that now
but you go back and you really still do
care about the stand-up work on it a lot
I do I do I'm going to do a Netflix
special July yeah which is exciting I'm
gonna be in Ridgefield Connecticut I'm
gonna be the Wilbur in Boston in July
and it's going well
I'm scared about taping a special
because you know some people are so good
you know sound like I didn't watch the
Louie CK special right cuz I know what
you know I don't like seeing people who
are better at me than things right which
is why I don't watch pornography like
pornography that raises your self-esteem
yes like it's a guy with a one-inch
penis that's done in four seconds that's
the porn I watch exactly but I started
going into the Improv and doing a lot of
stand-up into the comedy store and the
and and the Comedy Cellar in New York
and it the improv for wild Paul
McCartney kept coming in to watch to the
show wait a minute so you'd be up there
doing stand-up just having a set on a
regular knife and the most famous person
in the world Paul McCartney is sitting
in the audience but not this like once
like a few times that he loves comedy
he's like a great guy he was always
hilarious that's why we like the Beatles
cuz they're so funny and and I would say
hello to him afterwards nervously and
then you know after a couple of times I
thought you know maybe I have to come
out to lunch right because you're
thinking maybe nobody does that
yeah maybe like the lonely cheerleader
that no one asks out to the prom right
and so I come out too much maybe you'd
like to hang out with with me since he's
enjoyed me and and so I had a piece of
paper to pan and uses music and movies
we know each other a little bit and I
and I gave it some like hey how do I
reach you and he goes like this he was
very nice but you think they said no
yeah but you know he'd found a nice way
to do it but then the next day my friend
was like hey I took pictures of you
while you were talking to Paul McCartney
and he found a photo of that moment so
this let's look at this move upon
[Applause]
that level of family it's not happening
you